Governor great to see you good to be
back uh how's it going how are you
feeling about running for president I
feel great you know I've been in it for
five weeks
um I feel really good I feel like you
know what I'm saying to people is
starting to break through in terms of
what we're seeing in the polling you
know we're nine percent now in New
Hampshire only four points behind
Governor DeSantis and for five weeks
that's pretty good so we're feeling good
about the way it's going and I will tell
you that I'm enjoying myself and I think
it comes through
the big elephant in the room is not here
um Donald Trump way ahead in the polls
at the moment for the Republican
nomination how are you going to knock
him out
directly
there's no way to do this like playing
bumper pool Pierce and I think that's
the biggest uh mistake that my
adversaries in this race are making they
think somehow if they you know maybe
kind of in a sideways looking way they
say something negative about Trump that
people will get it and then they'll go
to them look there's one lane to the
Republican nomination in my opinion and
Donald Trump's at the head of that lane
and if you want to be the man you got to
beat the man and you got to go right
through him and how do you do that
whilst not alienating the not in
significant number of people in his Mega
base who blindly support Trump who don't
even care he's been indicted on criminal
charges they believe it's all a stitch
up because he's told them that how do
you manage to knock him out and wipe him
out of the race and keep those people
coming with you which you need to win a
general election well look first off I
think that the group that you'd have to
be worried about alienating is
relatively small compared to the entire
Republican primary and then in the
general election if you do knock him out
look those folks are going to look at
the choice between me and Joe Biden and
even if they feel some resentment
towards me from knocking out Donald
Trump they don't want 82 year old Joe
Biden let alone 86 year old Joe Biden in
the white house so and I think when they
listen to me about the issues peers you
know I want to send the National Guard
to the border to interdict fentanyl I'll
actually build the wall as opposed to
the 47 miles that Donald Trump built in
four years that's 12 miles a year he
needs like 40 years as president to be
able to finish the entire wall he said
he's going to repeal and replace
Obamacare didn't get it done said he was
going to balance the budget he added Six
Trillion to the debt so Republican
primary voters deserve two things the
truth
which they're not getting from Joe Biden
or Donald Trump and results on issues
they care about Donald Trump had a
chance to do that as president if he
didn't why should we give him another
you in your previous life were a lawyer
you were a prosecutor Federal prosecutor
I think you had 130 cases that you waged
against all sorts of people from the
mafia to the Bloods and crypt gangs to
uh Jared kushner's Dad yes who actually
went to prison as a result of one of
your prosecutions you never lost a case
I remember you telling me this years ago
when I interviewed you at CNN very proud
I think I said to you how many how many
did you win and you said ask me a
different question ask me how many I
lost right because the answer was a big
fat zero that's an impressive record
your record politically is not as
unblemished no do you think you can win
this or could he go down as a as a big L
at the end of the day well everyone's
going to lose except for one person at
the end so you know you ran that risk
when you run but I absolutely believe I
can win this race and the reason is
because I think the the American people
are tired of politicians who talk but
don't deliver results and in the end
what you can say lots of different
things about my tenure in New Jersey and
it certainly wasn't unblemished but it
was consequential we saved 150 billion
dollars reforming the pensions for
public workers with a democratic
legislature no one thought that could
ever get done we fired the entire Camden
City Police Department because they were
ineffective and in the last 10 years
since we brought that new police
department in murders down 75 percent
what do you most regret about your
tenure as governor
that's gosh I mean the George Washington
Bridge stuff I mean that's easy answer
um you know three people who went off on
a toot on their own
um and did something that was incredibly
childish and juvenile I fired them
because of it and but it it probably
caused a year a year and a half of
tumult in our state that was unnecessary
and in the end I'm accountable for that
because I hired those people
um I didn't know about what went on but
when I found out I fired them and
regardless of whether I knew or not I'm
accountable
you've always struck me as a straight
shooter you're a pugilist by Nature
someone punches you you punch him back
Trump's like that you know that yep um
you were with him for a long time I was
what was the Tipping Point for you to
turn on Trump election night 2020
appears because when he stood up at 2 30
in the morning behind the Seal of the
president in the East room of the White
House and told the American people that
the election had been stolen when he had
no evidence to prove that it was to me
that's undercutting our democracy and
people's belief in it and that is
beneath the office that the people
blessed him with and I think that you
know no one likes to lose I've won and
I've lost winnings better and it makes
you feel better but when you get in this
game you know that you can lose and you
got to be a man about it stand up and
take your loss like a man and put the
country first so that was the night and
I said it on ABC that night that I
couldn't support what he was doing and I
couldn't support him if he was going to
continue when you saw the Aftershock of
that on January the 6th with the Riots
of the capital as a direct consequence
of his refusal to accept of course what
do you feel when you watch that
sick to my stomach
and and quite frankly astonished that
that could happen in our country I
expected that to see that in some other
country with a less developed democracy
some people have sort of tried to play
it down but I remember watching that and
thinking I don't think I've ever seen
anything like that in the United States
I've never seen anything like in the
United States where the actual
embodiment the physical embodiment the
freedom and democracy was under attack
by Americans whipped into a frenzy by a
President Who simply could not accept
that he'd lost an a fair democratic
election I mean he keeps talking about
it being stolen buddy as I keep saying
to him where's the evidence that was
stolen there isn't any evidence there
isn't any and look
you could talk a lot of things about
about Donald Trump in terms of how he
lies
but let's just look at January 6th he
stood in the ellipse that day fired
those people up and said let's March to
the Capitol in our march with you
where the hell was he
he sent those people on a mission
to destroy the capital do you think he
meant for them to commit acts of
violence I don't think he cared
right which is as bad yeah I don't think
he cared I think what he wanted to do
was placed close to the edge of the
envelope as he could he wanted to
intimidate Mike Pence he wanted to
intimidate the Congress and try to buy
any delay he could to try to stay in
office you know he told me one time the
White House was the most luxurious Place
he'd ever lived in in his life and he
didn't want to leave well you know what
if I go to the White House I'm not going
to care how luxurious it is I'm going to
be honored that I'm in the same place
where John Adams and Thomas Jefferson
and Abraham Lincoln sat and we're going
to try to do big things for this country
he doesn't care about that he just wants
to do big things for himself you've been
a prosecutor when you see the evidence
obviously we've had the Stormy Daniels
case all right that may be relatively
small potatoes by comparison to some of
the others but it was an indictment
we've then had the the documents issue
at Mar-A-Lago which seems altogether
much more serious then we've got what
maybe more indictments coming on what
happened with the Georgia phone call and
there may be more to follow after that
as well around January the 6th he could
end up with four different sets of
indictments on criminal charges and yet
still be able to run as president and in
fact still be able to win as president
and potentially if he gets put into a
prison cell which is almost Unthinkable
but it could technically happen he could
still be president from his prison cell
is that right that that can happen in
your country no it's not right for it to
happen in our country but I'll tell you
our Founders never thought that anybody
would be such an egomaniac that when
charged with crimes they would still run
you know I remember everything that that
the media and a lot of people in America
said when I was a young man about
Richard Nixon
but when Richard Dixon was confronted
with the reality
that he was going to put the country
through an impeachment trial he put the
country first and he resigned even
though Nixon didn't think he should have
resigned but he did it for the good of
the country can anyone imagine Donald
Trump even doing that for the good of
the country and that's the problem I
love the people who say I know he's not
a great guy but I like his policies well
the question is if you like his policies
why would you ever hire him to get those
policies implemented they would say back
at you all right but you were with him
for a long time knowing exactly what
he's like I mean I've known Trump a long
time he hasn't really changed his
character he's gotten worse he's always
told Whoppers over the years right I
don't think he's been the king of
veracity for no decades right so to
suddenly wake up and go all right he's a
terrible liar I can't be with him
anymore how do you defend yourself
against the charge well you should have
stood up against him much earlier sure
because you know this this reminds me of
a story about one of your former Prime
Ministers prime minister Cameron I went
over to visit in 2015 and he was getting
ready to run free election and he's
telling me it's only 48 days the
election season in Great Britain he said
how the hell do you guys do the this for
as long as you do it and to explain your
system to me and I said well David I
said the easiest way to describe it is
in America you don't necessarily get the
vote for you want to vote for you get to
vote for who's left
and in 2016 I ran against Donald Trump I
lost
who was left with Donald Trump and
Hillary Clinton I did not want Hillary
Clinton to be president and I will tell
you as we sit here right now peers I
have no regrets of helping Donald Trump
get elected in 2016 because I think
Hillary Clinton would have been a
monumentally worst president nominee
this time round and beat to you again to
be nominee would you vote for him yeah
I've answered this one before no you
wouldn't no what's the difference
between the last time undercutting of
the democracy
as I said when you show you don't have
respect even if you you would be more
prepared for Biden to win again in that
scenario I I hope that neither one of
them is the nominee but I couldn't vote
if they are the two nominees well then
the option is that by you would help
Biden no no I go on vacation
yeah but by not voting you would
potentially help him win well how would
you feel if Biden won by one vote and it
turned out to be you Chris Christie
guess what in our electoral college
system one vote in New Jersey will not
make the difference so good try
for those who don't know you what are
the best and worst things about your
personality
if you're going to be president I think
I think the best things about my
personality is that I'm honest I'm
direct and I care
um I really have a soft empathetic heart
um that displays itself in a lot of
different ways with me as a father and
and also with me as somebody who cares
deeply about the drug crisis in our
country and wanting to give people a
second chance to give them the tools
they need to recover from the disease of
addiction
um and I care about that I've lost
friends in that way one very dear friend
and you know I know how bad that is now
look when you're direct and you're
honest and you're blunt sometimes you
say things that you should have stayed
in your mouth
um and and I've done that at times over
my career and sometimes I'm too quick to
judge
do you have a temper like President
Biden it turns out as a ferocious
apparent mouth temper behind the scene
not as bad as him as it sounds from what
I've read lately but I can lose my
temper look I'm a sicilian American from
New Jersey so every once in a while
we'll get off with a few good ones I'm
here and there but never really to the
people
um you know in a way that makes people
not want to work for me in fact I'm
really proud of the fact that the group
that's working on this campaign for me
are the same people that worked for me
in 2009 when I ran for governor the
first time and we've been together now
for 14 years and I think you know that's
the difference between me and Donald
Trump in the end all my people have been
with me for 14 years and haven't left me
Donald Trump if you look at it not one
of his White House Chiefs of Staff would
come back and work for him not one of
his secretaries of State his secretaries
of defense his attorney's General his
his Secretary of the Treasury these
people will not come back and work for
him and and that tells you something
doesn't it if you were president again
none of those people would come back and
work for him because working for him was
so awful
what would it say about America if Trump
wins again
look I think the rest of the world will
look at us and think why would you want
someone of that awful character and that
mediocre performance to be your
president and I think the rest of the
world would question our votes but let's
face it peers there have been a lot of
times we look at other countries too and
we question the people that they've
elected I mean how many prime ministers
have you guys had in the last like oh my
God three years
right so so we all have questions about
that but in the end
America's role is a little bit different
and we are the leader of democracy
around the world we are the arsenal of
democracy We Are The Shining Light to
people who look for us to be able to
stand strong and defend Liberty in the
world and we need somebody different
than Donald Trump or Joe Biden to do
that it's very interesting you raised
that because I've been really struck by
the fact the Republican party in fact of
all the candidates very split over this
issue of Ukraine and how involved
America should be some of the candidates
implacably opposed to any more
involvement if I want to remove any more
money and and military hardware and so
on many others completely full-on behind
Ukraine and supporting President Biden
and giving them what they need where do
you sit with this I sit forward behind
Ukraine look for a few reasons one
um you know we talked about the fact
that Governor DeSantis interviewed with
you
um and and you know he had said that to
Tucker Carlson that it was a territorial
dispute let me tell you what a
territorial dispute is when they survey
your property at home and your fence is
8 which is over on your on your
neighbor's property that's a territory
not rolling tanks and artillery into a
freedom-loving country and killing
innocent people and taking their land by
force we have to stand up against those
kind of authoritarian aggressors and
remember Vladimir Putin Donald Trump
says he's a terrific guy and a great
leader I don't know it doesn't look like
that to me I stand behind Ukraine for
that reason second it's a proxy war with
China
China is funding the Russians in this
war they are coordinating with Iran to
provide what happens with regard to
potentially invading Taiwan that's right
where I was going Piers you know the
Chinese are going to look at this and
say does America stand up for its
friends taiwan's a friend of America if
we're not going to stand up for Ukraine
guess what president XI another guy who
Donald Trump thinks is a great guy and
handsome too
um you know he he he thinks that of G
she'll be in Taiwan
um faster than you could say Jimmy
Carter
um if we don't stand up in Ukraine and
so to me they have deserved our support
because of who they are and we in our
own national interests have to support
Ukraine to send a very clear message to
China Iran and North Korea
to give fighting if you if you and Trump
got in the ring he loves his UFC and
stuff like that right if he got on the
Octagon you and him who'd win come on
okay 78 years old
I'd kick his ass
I mean we know that Elon Musk and Mark
Zuckerberg apparently going to get I
can't wait for that one did you see that
picture of Zuckerberg yeah looking
pretty buff it does if I were Elon I'd
be a little bit worried I mean would you
be prepared to be on the undercard
you're against Trump
look I'll fight Donald Trump anywhere he
wants in any Arena he wants whether it's
on a debate stage or in the Octagon he's
mocked your weight Trump yeah look at
him Arnold Schwarzenegger I mean for
goodness sakes come on I mean look you
know what here's the here's the bottom
line Pierce I you know for the last 30
years I've struggled with my weight like
tens of millions of Americans struggle
with their weight and there are times
where I do well and there are times when
I don't do very well
um and it's a struggle and for him to be
such a child an infant and make those
kind of remarks especially I guess when
he's staying up in Bedminster New Jersey
there are no mirrors where he is because
all he needs to do is look at himself
and what he should do first work on
himself then when he gets himself
because you know he wears those ties you
know well as long as dies yeah eight
feet long because he told me this
because they slenderized him let me tell
it fail not working okay but here's the
thing at least I've never pretended to
be any thing that I'm not
I own my weaknesses I own my strengths
and I'm transparent about it and people
can see it and when he says that stuff
about me to me coming from him it's a
compliment do you do you feel you were
born to run
well it depends on what kind of running
you're talking about
on our last stop for president
uh look I think that that for somebody
there's a reason I'm asking you that
specific question well of course and I
think that
your God God gives you certain skills
talents and interests and what you make
of them can lead you to where you go in
your life I was really getting to who
sang Born to Run oh you're getting Mr
Springsteen because the other most
famous person come out of New Jersey
yeah how many times have you seen him in
concert
currently 148th
when was the last time the last time
they've done so right yeah he is the
last time was uh
uh in April at the Prudential Center in
Newark New Jersey have you ever met him
yes number of times because it wasn't
period when he was quite critical of you
well when I endorsed Trump he was not
quite yes too happy with me did that
sever the relationship it cooled it it
cooled it brings back on track now
you've been hammering Trump things are
getting better
things are getting better the New Jersey
Boys Are Back Back Together that's right
because now you're saying the right
stuff well I've seen stuff he agrees
with and I think it's right did you have
that conversation privately with him
did he try and persuade you to no no no
no he more reacted to some of the stuff
I was doing um and commented to me
privately about it what did he say I'm
not going to tell you well give me a
hint that's between me and the boss
Prince Harry in 2012 when Hurricane
Sandy I was at CNN when hurricane said
he swept through Manhattan I remember
the building CNN was in swaying it was
scary stuff the power going out the
water it was Mayhem uh Prince Harry
famously visited uh your state your
guest at the time and you did a
walkabout with him we did uh things have
sort of moved on for him since then what
do you make of what's going on with
Megan and Harry and their journey to
Freedom I've never met Megan so it's
hard for me and I I try as someone who
is a public figure to not judge too much
based upon what I read or see so I don't
have really any opinions on Megan I
found Harry when I met him in 2012 to be
a really kind-hearted young man
but also a pretty sad and Confused one
and I'll give you one example he he um
we were to exchange gifts
when he got off the helicopter in New
Jersey and I had a fleece like the
fleece I was wearing during Hurricane
Sandy I gave him a fleece that said
Prince Harry on it he didn't give me a
gift back and I thought all right well
we must have gotten the briefing wrong
or whatever we later went back to the
governor's beach house to have lunch
together after the walkabout and um
he said now look I have a gift for you
he said but I didn't want to give it in
front of all those people and I will
give it to you now but only if you
promise not to open it until I leave
and I said why and he said because they
make me give this and it makes me very
uncomfortable
so I said fine Harry and he goes into
his bag and is this wrapped gift and he
puts it on the table and I honored his
request and didn't open it when we
opened it afterwards it was a framed
picture framed autographed picture of
himself
I swear to you and and and now I knew in
in a way why he was sad
because nobody would have made him do
that he doesn't have to give people
signed pigeons himself he said they make
me give this it's ridiculous and well I
don't know because again
you look at me you're not thinking
royalty right so but I saw the other day
he was he got a commercial flight and
the steward posted a picture and Harry
had given him a signed copy of his book
it's obviously he's stick even now well
it goes around look I think a signed
copy of your book is different this is a
framed picture of himself what did you
do with it I gave it to my daughter
um who thought he was really cute so so
she kept the picture and she still has
it it's interesting what's happened to
them because uh the Spotify executive
kind of summed up what many people think
and called them effing little grifters
yeah
um very unpopular in the UK now because
they've basically trashed the royal
family so yeah obviously what do you
think of that I think it's all you're a
big family man I am I think it's awful I
think if you have those kind of disputes
with your father with your brother other
members of your family that that's fine
families fight but they need to fight
inside the family right and and I think
when he decided to go public with all of
that and the only conclusion I can draw
are two one that it was somehow
cathartic for him and he's obviously a
troubled young man and who could wonder
about that because of his mother's
passing at such a young age but secondly
it had to be to make money
and and I think that that to trash your
family for cash I totally agree um I
think is is beneath someone who's been
given all the honors he's been given
over the course of his life and so but
the good thing is I'm hopeful that you
know his father now has what he's always
wanted
and I'm hoping that King Charles will be
um forgiving I think he's tried but I
think he's pretty much at the stage of
washing his hands of him now because the
the attacks well that's incredibly sad
if that's what it is I think he can't
trust him every time he turns up he just
takes all the material he Garners back
and puts it in some other publication
and I think if that's what it is then
then you know as even as a father there
are moments where you just have to walk
away but I'll tell you as a father of
four that it would be really hard for me
to walk away from any of my children
yeah and if that's who the king is it's
a pretty sad place for him too not his
fault necessarily at all but a sad place
for him at a moment in his life when he
should be really pretty happy he's got
the woman he's always loved and he's got
the job he always wanted it's pretty
good about over a decade ago I hung out
with you and your family we did I had a
great pleasure of going to your home and
meeting your lovely wife and some of
your kids
family's massive to you isn't it it's
probably the most important thing in
your life right it is my wife and my
children and my siblings and my dad my
mom has pastors you know a long time ago
um they're the most important thing in
my life because in the end one of the
things about getting some measure of of
notoriety
is that you know you can let it take
over your head and one of the things
that's always been great is you know
I've been able to go home to my family
and you know they don't treat me any
differently you know my younger son
Patrick one time when I was admonishing
him when I was governor that he had to
do his homework and he wouldn't do it
for his mother and I said look
this is my house I set the rules you go
and do your homework now and he said he
was 10 years old at the time he said
fine and then he went to storm up the
stairs to his room and he turned around
he goes just remember something dad
you're not the governor of this house
family's always been and they're now
older now they're now 29 27 22 and 20.
um and they the biggest gift I've gotten
from them
is they really like each other
they hang with each other I've had the
same thing with my son and it's so great
right after years of fighting they got
to their 20s and then they all became
great friends yeah I love that and what
a gift right because and also I don't
know about you but I I've read or saw
Tick Tock I think of somebody saying the
real definition of success for any man
is if his children when they get to
adult age still want to hang out with
them yeah and mine do thank God and it's
a great joy to me and yours do yeah but
I do think that's an interesting
yardstick of real success in life it is
if your kids still want to be around you
when they don't have to be that's right
they're not relying on you that says a
lot about you as a human being it does
and I think for my wife and I we're
really proud of that but we don't take
any chances you know uh peers we also
bought a beach house at the Jersey Shore
so they have some place to come back to
that was very attractive so yeah I got a
place in La for the same reason that's
exactly right you got to do that so
that's what I call is a family insurance
policy just in case come back to the
beach
if you just go forward a bit you knock
out Trump you win the presidency
inauguration day what do you say to the
American people
that it's time for us once again to put
our country first it's time for us to
put aside some of our differences and
figure out areas where we can work
together and compromise and that the
kind of President I would hope to be
would be one that would be able to forge
those compromises and sacrifice my own
popularity to be able to make action
happen your mother said to you before
she died that far more important to be
respected than to be loved because if
you're respected the love comes down the
line I thought it was really good advice
it was great would you take that advice
into a presidency it's it's the advice I
take into every day of my life it's not
just into my jobs it's into the way I
deal with my kids too
I want to be a someone who they respect
in addition to someone they love because
if they respect me then they're going to
come to me when they have problems
they're going to come to me for advice
they're going to come to me when they
just need to cry
and that's the kind of respect that if I
were to become president I'd want the
American people to know that every day
I'd be working as hard as I could to
make them feel that respect for me but
more importantly for them to feel proud
of their country and I think there are
moments now where Americans don't feel
proud of our country because of some of
the things we're failing to do and I
want us to do the big things the thing
that I always wanted when I was governor
I used to say to my folks all the time
don't tell me about what's how something
will affect my ratings
today tell me if it's something that
really is consequential I want to be a
governor of consequence and I believe I
was
and that's the kind of presence I want
to be to do the big things to be a
president of the consequence Governor
great to see you again good to see you
pierce